[Music]
so what is rapamycin
so rapamycin is a drug that
is a naturally occurring uh anti-fungal
agent made by a bacteria that was
discovered on easter island
uh back in the 1960s otherwise known as
rapa nui
right rapa nui is the correct name for
easter island and the bacteria
streptomyces hydroscopicus which was
discovered there
by a group of explorers explorers maybe
the wrong word but people doing sort of
medical prospecting
a group from montreal i believe in 1966
they took a bunch of soil and dirt back
from rapa nui
to the lab in montreal where it sort of
sat there
unattended too for about five years uh a
chemist a very astute chemist by the
name of siren seagal
right now yeah he related to steven
seagal
no difference and no ponytail
fortunately
um so siren did some really interesting
chemistry
isolated the compound and noticed it had
these really remarkable properties
which was it was the most potent
anti-fungal agent
he had ever seen or the world had ever
seen frankly
at the time as his son ajit tells the
story
who i've gotten to know a little bit he
felt he had basically
come on to the biggest block duster
blockbuster cure for athlete's foot the
world was ever going to know
and right about that time the company he
worked for closed its montreal
headquarters actually laid many people
off ordered the
destruction of all non-viable compounds
and shipped him off to new jersey
in one of the greatest acts of
scientific fortuity he did not
follow orders and he instead stuck
said rapamycin into a little mini
freezer
that he and his family transported to
their new home in new jersey they kept
it in the
freezer for many years until ultimately
another drug company purchased the
company he worked for
and the new management said hey anybody
working on anything interesting he said
i'm working on this thing interesting
that i haven't looked at in a few years
and they said
bring it out it must have been an
interesting uh lawyer conversation
based on the not following orders
continue yeah so
out came uh rapamycin which he named uh
mycen and you know mycen is typically
the uh the prefix the suffix i guess
that we use or what's the what's the
second part of a word called
yeah for for antimicrobial agents and of
course rap
as a tribute to the rapa nui like a
zithromycin
correct yep so it it quickly became
clear that this had remarkable
anti-proliferative properties so it
could stop things from proliferating so
that was obviously a big part of just
fungi right exactly and in particular
um it was very effective at making a
certain type of lymphocyte
which is a white type of white blood
cell not proliferate
and it then basically went down the path
eventually
pfizer then bought amorous which was the
company that bought his previous company
whose name i don't even remember at this
point
pfizer ended up pursuing this and it was
fda approved in 1999
for treatment of organ transplantation
so patients that have an organ
transplanted
have to be put on a really heavy regimen
of drugs to suppress
a part of their immune system called the
cellular immune system
that will attack a foreign organ that's
what is that called host graft
no no graft versus host is actually when
the
organ usually it's in the case of
lymphoma or leukemia when someone has a
bone marrow transplant
and the the graft what they've been
transplanted attacks the host
i see it yeah yeah this is this is
really host versus graft but we don't
usually talk about that yeah but
traditional sort of
you know rejection actually i did a
really cool podcast on the topic of
organ transplantation history with a guy
named chris son and day
and it's i mean i know this subject well
but having a discussion with chris
really opened my eyes to just what a
beautiful story it is
and what the big breakthroughs were with
drug development
and how you know at one point it was
like all you could give people was
prednisone and
you couldn't save anybody and then you
know you had
other drugs like cyclosporine that were
introduced but then you get into this
third generation of amazing drugs like
rapamycin that took organ
uh you know preservation to a to a
higher level
now you're not swapping kidneys
how do you know well at least not since
the last time you sold one
tijuana settle a bet but
uh why would you take grapplemyson i
know i'm skipping ahead a little bit
well let's yeah so let's skip ahead so
so 99 this drug comes on the market for
um for for organ rejection
and about 12 years later a study gets
published by rich miller randy strong
and colleagues
as part of what's called the
interventions testing program or the itp
which is an amazing nih-funded program
that tests
molecules that are believed to have a
shot at enhancing longevity and it does
so in a
really really rigorous way probably the
most rigorous way we can test
small animals i've interviewed rich
miller as well
probably one of my five favorite
podcasts in terms of like nerding out on
all of the molecules that can
potentially impr impact longevity
and rapamycin was in many ways the
poster child for the itp program
because um first of all it's hard to get
anything to live longer second of all
when they were
making the formulation for the rapamycin
to feed the mice and these were very
special mice these were not your typical
crappy lab mice that have
no bearing whatsoever to real animals
these are a very special type
of mice that are much more akin to real
animals and that's a very
important distinction between what
happens in 99 percent of mouse research
which
is almost inapplicable to humans and
it's why
so many drugs that get tested in these
you know b6 mice and things like that
you know show some marker of success and
they become wild
failures beyond the mice but this was
different
they had trouble getting the formulation
to work and by the time they finally did
the mice were like 20 months old which
means they're almost at the end of their
life
they're like 70 year old 65 year old
mice
and they contemplated just scrapping the
experiment but they were like ah screw
it let's just
run it late so they started feeding the
treatment group with rapamycin and the
placebo group get to continue eating
their regular chow
i guess it was oral administration yes
it was the rapamycin was mixed into
their chow
and lo and behold the rapamycin group
despite initiating treatment so late in
life had a
staggering improvement in lifespan
there's been so many itps that have
replicated this i don't want to misquote
it but something to the effect of like a
17 or 19
improvement in the males or in the
females and 11 to 12 percent in the
males
and remember the itp uses a very
rigorous way of assessing this which is
they're taking a look at the remaining
life
or sorry they're taking a look at total
life not just remaining life
so it's a it's it's an even higher bar
to clear what
how much lifespan elongation happens
they of course immediately went and
repeated the study
administering the dose when they were
younger and saw an even greater response
this has been repeated over and over and
over again
um and to my knowledge there is not a
single animal study
that has tested this hypothesis that has
not found
this result oh that's wild um which
again is
very unusual yeah so it's just
replicated
over and over and over it's replicated
non-stop uh what is also
interesting is when looking at other
markers
other interesting things such as vision
and hearing and other markers of health
span we continue to see improvements in
these things
for animals as well and as i think we
even spoke about before a guy named matt
caberline who i'm
just interviewed for a second time for
the podcast
has been studying this in companion dogs
and looking at heart function because as
you know
basically two things kill companion dogs
primarily
heart failure and cancer and so the
question is
what would you be able to do to mitigate
um especially heart failure congestive
heart failure in dogs
especially large dogs which are more
susceptible to this
and again the the the results though the
research is limited because there's not
an enormous
interest in funding this research and
it's expensive to fund research
in dogs that live so long um
it's all pointing in the same direction
so
when you contrast metformin and
rapamycin
you have the opposite thing right in
metformin we have tons of human data
that are not randomized but are
suggesting
in cohorts that metformin is also
protective
uh but in a subset of people that have
diabetes so it's not as clear how
protective metformin will be in
in people that do not in the itp
metformin did not succeed
in other words metformin did not extend
life
in the mice when given alone when it was
given with rapamycin it did but you
could argue that was all the rapamycin
um i'm more bullish on rapa simply
because i'm
you know i've been taking it now for
three years
outside of you can hear dog whistles
um outside of um you know the aphthous
ulcers which are the most annoying side
effect of them
those are those little mouth little
mouth sores you get a canker sore
yep yeah um which you don't get i don't
get them de novo but if i
like if one of my kids headbutts me
which they do at
an alarming frequency um and my if i
break a piece of my gum like it's going
to be an aptus ulcer
although what is it called again
aphthous ulcer apathy yeah
a p h t h
o s yeah yeah
nasty nasty it doesn't sound fun so
that's the only
is that the only documented in healthy
normals i don't know who has
would fund this research if anyone would
um or i don't know what i guess i don't
even know what the
measurements the metrics would be but
well that gets to the problem
we don't have a meaningful biomarker of
aging
yeah i mean that's full stop the biggest
problem in aging research today
hands down nothing else matters yeah
when you don't have
a really good biomarker for aging
we're sort of sitting around twiddling
our thumbs
pontificating doing studies that look at
things that aren't that interesting
or things that are interesting but are
like
you know first order second order you
know but we just we can't see the whole
polynomial right like if you think back
to like what a taylor series is in
calculus if you're
trying to use a polynomial to estimate
sine x the first order term is
x equals y like that's interesting for
about that much but you know when you
really want to know
x minus x cubed over three factorial
plus x to the five over five factorial
like when you wanna really start
figuring out the shape of this thing
you've gotta
you're just gonna need better tools
you